kamala harris releases a video betraying
the actual marxist philosophy of the new
democratic party while joe biden shouts
gibberish
anthony fought she touts biden while
trump rips him and we assess the final
state of the race i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet
is it expressvpn.com tomorrow is the
election guys tomorrow is the election
we're gonna get to
everything election related get to the
final rundown
where we stand in the polls because
tomorrow the votes start and tomorrow
night
it's all over and then it's just a
matter of vote counting we'll get to
that in just one moment first
let's talk about something that you
should have done for yourself this year
if you haven't already done it there's
still time to do it i'm talking of
course about straightening
out those teeth back when you were a
teenager you had braces didn't you and
then
your orthodontist said you know these
retainers you're gonna have to wear
these and just wear these pretty
regularly and about three weeks later
you flush them down the toilet you never
look back
well now your teeth moved out of place
because that's what happens over time
and you want to straighten those teeth
out again but you don't want the ugly
braces because you're not 13 years old
so why not go get some candid clear
aligners they're comfortable removable
practically invisible unlike
wire braces i've been using candid
myself to straighten these amazing
chompers you can transform your smile
too without anybody noticing plus
your treatment is prescribed and
monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist who's an expert in tooth
movement it's all done from the comfort
and convenience of your own home
candid only works with orthodontists
never general dentists like other
companies plus
your supervising orthodontist will be
with you every step of the way with
candid your treatment includes remote
monitoring by the same orthodontist who
created your plan so you never have to
wonder how you're doing you will always
know which of course i love the average
candid treatment is just six months
you'll start seeing results way before
then
it costs thousands of bucks less than
braces start straightening your teeth
today right now all my listeners can
save 75 bucks on candid's starter kit
head on over to candid co.com
shapiro use code shapiro that is
candidco.com
shapiro use code shapiro take advantage
of this limited time offer to save 75
bucks on that starter kit candidco.com
shapiro use code shapiro all righty so
tomorrow the voting begins so let's
assess the state of the race
according to 538 this is nate silver and
if you don't like data
skip the next 10 minutes okay because
we're going to talk a little bit of data
here i know there are a lot of folks on
the right who want to ignore the data
because they assume that the data
is bad well i'm not somebody who
operates in the absence of evidence so
we will see how the data stacks up if it
turns out that the polling is all wrong
every one of these pollsters needs to
learn to code like right now
because there are a lot of polls being
done and here is the thing here is the
thing
despite the fact that nationally joe
biden is up very very wide
the fact is that the polls would not
have to be wrong in order for donald
trump to win this election
that's the thing that people are
ignoring when they are getting very
sanguine on the left about how this
election is going to go
i'm looking at the real clear politics
polling average right now
in the real clear politics polling
average in the top battleground states
biden is up on average 2.9 points
and nationally he's up anywhere from six
to ten points by virtually every poll
but in the battleground states biden is
up not all that much
in florida it's within margin of error
in north carolina margin of error in
iowa there's a big poll that came out
over the weekend we'll talk about it in
a second
in which joe biden was down at 41 and
this is a pretty well respected poll
and donald trump was at 48 in minnesota
biden is up only 4.3 percent
in pennsylvania 4.3 percent in arizona
it is margin of error basically dead
even
in nevada biden is up only 3.6 in
michigan
he's up only 5.1 percent in ohio it's
dead even in wisconsin he's up 6.6
percent texas
is also very close and georgia is
basically dead even so what does that
mean
it means that there are basically three
election scenarios that are worth
talking about one is a very very
tight trump victory trump ekes out an
electoral college victory
he doesn't win the popular vote there's
pretty much no shot at him winning the
popular vote at this point
but it is possible that he picks up
north carolina he wins florida he wins
arizona
and then he picks up one more state
where he picks up pennsylvania or he
picks up wisconsin right picks up
michigan
right most likely those is pennsylvania
and democrats are very nervous about
pennsylvania as we'll talk about in a
second
that is definitely a possibility and the
polls do not have to be wrong
for that possibility to materialize in
fact if there is a surge of trump voters
on election day
there's a lot of focus right now in
early voting focusing on early voting is
almost always a mistake when you see
people
analysts who are looking at the early
voting numbers the reason that's a
mistake
is because in 2016 they assumed that
because so many people were voting for
hillary early
that meant that hillary was going to win
that that was just a bunch of new voters
who were voting early it turns out that
early voting might just be cannibalizing
the vote from election day
right you meant to vote on election day
and instead you were like you know what
i'm not wasting my time at the polls
kova's on and so i'm gonna go vote uh a
week early
so you didn't vote twice right you voted
one so it's not as though your early
vote mattered more than your late vote
what may be happening here is a bit of a
cannibalization of the later vote by
democrats they're all voting early
meanwhile republicans are waiting until
election day and you might get a big
trump turnout on election day in fact
cnn ruled out this possibility yesterday
they called this the republican
surg scenario and they trotted out this
map the republican search scenario
is exactly the map that i was talking
about where trump wins north carolina
florida texas arizona
uh and uh he wins ohio and pennsylvania
as well as well as iowa
right this is the most likely trump
victory map the one that we are looking
at right now this is from cbs actually
right this is where trump wins 279
electoral votes and biden wins 259 and
it's a very close election even though
biden wins the popular vote
overwhelmingly right this is
the best case scenario i think for trump
the second possible scenario is that joe
biden
wins but he wins narrowly right that
biden flips pennsylvania
right there go back to that map for one
second biden wins pennsylvania and if
biden wins pennsylvania
then that is enough to shift the vote
to joe biden right basically everything
comes down to pennsylvania now the big
problem of course is that pennsylvania
is going to be counting votes for days
after the election so if this thing
comes down to pennsylvania
election night just going it's not going
to end for days on end
the states that report the fastest
florida reports pretty fast north
carolina
starts to report but it takes a while
for north carolina to come in
your first indicator as to how the
knight's going to go is probably going
to be florida
so if florida comes in fast and it comes
in for trump then democrats are going to
get
very very nervous if florida comes in
blue the election is all but over at
that point like right off the bat so
florida is going to be
your first indicator as to where things
lie okay so scenario number one is trump
picks out a narrow victory scenario
number two is biden eaks out a narrow
victory
scenario number three is that biden just
blows him out right i mean that's a
possibility too biden is
up in a massive way nationally in a way
that hillary clinton was not hillary
clinton was up
three to five points nationally she
ended up winning by about three points
nationally
in the popular vote of course and then
she ended up losing extremely narrowly
in those blue firewall states and then
pretty broadly in places like
iowa and ohio it is possible that joe
biden
bucks the trend here and biden pulls it
out in north carolina
he pulls it out in florida like things
have narrowed in the last week or so
and this is the thing momentum seems to
be with trump at this point
part of that is because you knew there
was going to be an inevitable narrowing
right that usually happens at the very
end of elections
there's a bit of a narrowing so that is
not particularly
unforeseeable but you could end up with
a scenario in which biden wins
everything
right right now if there were no toss-up
states if you look at the the
real clear politics no toss-up map then
what you would see
is biden winning a fairly broad
electoral college victory he'd win 335
electoral votes if the election
were to hold up to the real clear
politics polling average including
pulling out florida and georgia and
arizona
i'm doubtful that it looks like that my
guess is that if biden wins
it's gonna be fairly narrow in the
electoral college and fairly broadly in
the popular vote
so those are your your three scenarios
biden blowout by narrow victory trump
narrow victory right those are the three
scenarios and none of them
are impossible so nate silver over at 5
38 has a piece today titled i'm here to
remind you that trump
can still win right now sort of the
analysts are suggesting that he has
a 10 shot at winning but he says a 10
shot is not a zero percent shot
and nate silver says the reason that
president trump's chances in our
forecast are about 10
to not zero as in 2016 trump could
potentially benefit from the electoral
college
projected margins in the tipping point
states are considerably tighter than the
margins in the national popular vote
more specifically joe biden's lead in
pennsylvania the most likely tipping
point state is solid but not spectacular
about five points in our polling average
without pennsylvania biden does have
some paths to victory but there's no one
alternative state he can feel especially
secure about
so basically what nate silver is saying
is that if biden were to lose
pennsylvania basically trump wins the
election
well a lot of theories about why trump
can win about those shy trump voters are
probably wrong
systematic polling errors do occur it's
hard to predict them ahead of time or to
anticipate the reasons
in advance there is some chance says
nate's over the trump could win
illegitimately
to a large extent these scenarios are
beyond the scope of our forecast we'll
get to that in a second
because for all the talk about how trump
supporters are readying for violence and
all this
there's really only one group in the
country that's readying for violence and
the media
are fostering it the media are fostering
a notion that voter suppression
is taking over the country the
republicans are trying to throw out
legally
cast ballots and that is just really not
true there's not evidence of widespread
voter suppression we're going to have
record voting this year
voter turnout in georgia in texas in
florida is at all-time highs it is not
close
there's some chance of a recount
according to 538 about four percent or
an electoral college tie
around 0.5 percent and nate silver
concludes before we proceed further
short philosophical mode
i hate when people use his phrases such
as nate silver is giving biden a 90
chance we aren't giving anybody anything
instead we're mapping uncertainty in
other words if biden leads by about nine
points nationally and eight points in
wisconsin and five points in
pennsylvania and two points in florida
how does that translate into the
probability of victory people have a
tendency
to go from ninety percent shot means
that
there's a ten percent shot trump wins
you 90 shot means there's 100 chance
that biden wins and that obviously
is untrue right now the bottom line is
that if biden
were to win by two to three points in
the national popular vote
then there is a a better than average
chance a 57 shot that trump actually
wins the electoral college biden needs
to win
by somewhere between three and five
points in order for him to win the
national election so we'll see
how all of that turns out high voter
turnout the the kind of typical
conventional wisdom suggests that's bad
for republicans
the evidence there is pretty mixes
poster kirsten sultan sanderson has
said before okay we'll get to more of
the election analysis in just one second
first let's talk about safety and
security
so there are a thousand reasons why
protecting your home matters to you
protecting my home matters to me
i mean i have three small children three
under the age of seven that means that
they are running around constantly
trying to hurt themselves and i need to
have an
eye on them well the problem is i have
three young children i'm only one human
being
and i do not have six eyes also i only
have one body so i cannot divide myself
into three and then chase each one of
them around
which means i need cameras right i need
to be able to keep an eye on my property
and keep an eye on my kids this is what
ring does for me
whatever you call home ring has
everything you need to protect it see
and speak to whoever is at your front
door from anywhere with video doorbells
you can keep an eye on every corner of
your house with easy to install indoor
and outdoor cams you can protect your
whole home
with ring alarm a powerful affordable
whole home security system you can
easily
install yourself get a special offer on
the ring welcome kit right now at
ring.com
it comes with that ring video doorbell 3
and the chime pro it is the perfect way
to start your ring experience plus
free two-day shipping go to ring.com
that is ring.com
again ring.com go check them out right
now ring.com
and keep an eye on your property and
keep yourself safe okay so
back to the analysis as approximately 7
p.m eastern time on saturday
more than 90 million americans had
already voted in the 2020 presidential
election
according to the university of florida
u.s elections project this according to
frank camp
at daily wire that's a combined 57.6
million
mail-in ballots returned and 33.4
million in-person early votes cast
several states have come close to
matching their 2016 total turnout two
states have already exceeded those
totals
voters in texas have already cast nearly
10 million ballots voters in hawaii
have cast 484 000 votes that is 110
of their 2016 vote totals respectively
there are other states that are already
almost at their total vote total
this would be like montana washington
georgia new mexico they're all above
90 north carolina as well some states
appear to be holding back
maybe a lot of people are waiting for
election day pennsylvania has only had
38.4 percent of their 2016 total
ohio stands at 48.4
as of saturday looking at the polls in
the battleground states it appears to be
an increasingly tight race though
incumbent donald trump lag slightly
behind in
key areas so that is where things stand
right now right now if you had to sort
of
ballpark out which states you keep the
closest ion based on the real club
politics polling average
it would be north carolina and florida
would be early indicators of where the
election stands if trump loses either
one of those early then it's gonna be a
bad night for trump probably
um pennsylvania obviously is the key
swing state
at this point because trump still needs
to pick up pennsylvania
now there's been a lot of talk about
trump declaring premature victory
speaking to reporters on sunday evening
trump denied he would declare victory
prematurely
and there's a lot of rumors that
basically a lot of democrats are worried
that trump is going to come out the
night of the election because in-person
election voting is likely to skew trump
and say i won the election and then the
democrat won't concede and then there
will be chaos
trump has basically said he's not going
to do this trump also added i think it's
a terrible thing when ballots can be
collected after an election
i think it's a terrible thing when
states are allowed to tabulate ballots
for a long period of time after the
election
is over i mean honestly i don't think
that he's completely wrong about that
i mean we should generally know the
election results the night of the
election or as fast as humanly possible
it is also true that while we do
tabulate ballots for in some cases weeks
after the election
that's why the original vote totals
never look like the final vote totals
the idea of being able to receive
ballots after the election
uh which is what you're talking about in
pennsylvania is really not
is really not great trump is uh likely
to appear ahead in pennsylvania on
election night
but mail-in ballots are likely to come
in the following days
so mail-in ballots counted after
election day is set forth in state by
state rules are as legitimate as
in-person votes recorded
november 3rd many states won't be done
counting mail ballots by tuesday night
according
to axios in pennsylvania state law
prevents election officials from
counting
mail-in ballots before election day
night of counts may in fact be deceptive
so that is sort of where things stand
apparently the
trump team says that they are doing
better than they expected in texas
nevada north carolina arizona
and wisconsin as well there's one poll
that is scaring the devil
out of democrats right now and that is a
poll in iowa so trump did win iowa going
away
last time but biden was very competitive
in iowa now there's a new des moines
register mediacon iowa poll
it's it's conducted by selzer and
company which is the most
respected firm in the state it finds
trump leading biden in iowa by seven
points
the the two candidates were tied at 47
back in september this is according to
hank berry in writing for daily wire
the des moines register noted it has a
margin of error of plus or minus 3.4
percentage points however while men are
more likely to support trump and women
to support biden the gender gap has
narrowed independence have returned to
supporting the president a group that he
won
in 2016. so that looks like
more joe biden is fading than that trump
is gaining
so this has led trafalgar group chief
poster robert cahilly
to comment we've noticed that these
polls are predominantly missing the
hidden trump vote what we refer to as
the shy trump voter
there's a clear feeling among
conservatives and people that are for
the president they're not interested in
sharing their opinions so readily on the
telephone
we've people we've seen people beat up
harass docs have their houses torn up
because they express political opinions
that are not in line with the
politically correct establishment so
we're going to find out
you know whether that is true or not how
much of a shy trump vote there is also
the gap is closing a little bit in
wisconsin as well there's an alice intel
poll conducted between october 29th and
30th had found
president trump now leading joe biden
49.6 to 48.5 percent that atlas intel
poll
found that trump garnered 17 percent of
the black vote and 41
of the hispanic vote in wisconsin other
polls recently conducted
show trump may show trump still trailing
biden
in wisconsin if trump wins wisconsin
obviously he wins the election as well
he needs to win one of the following
three michigan wisconsin or pennsylvania
he does not need to win
two of the three or three of the three
assuming he holds all of the other
states that he was holding
so the election you can feel the
democrats want to celebrate prematurely
but they better be careful because they
did this with hillary and it didn't work
out particularly well for them
again florida is the one to keep your
early eye on because the votes come in
very very fast and they are tabulated
as they come in so
that variable voter turnout initial
estimates seem to indicate the
republicans in miami-dade county are
turning out to vote at a higher rate
than democrats
about 63 percent of the 428 000
registered republicans voting so far
compared to 56 of the 634 000 registered
democrats
in broward county around 61 percent of
democrats have voted so far 56 percent
of registered republicans
are as well biden america votes which is
a pro-biden organization obviously said
we've got to stop the bleeding
59 of registered voters have already
cast their vote in advance of
tuesday's election this according to ian
hayworth at daily wire so
again bottom line too close for comfort
too close for comfort for joe biden
you'd rather be in biden's shoes than be
in trump's shoes on election night at
this point given the polls
but this thing is not over and it means
that voter turnout the day of
is gonna have to be very very good for
for trump okay so what are the final
pitches for the various campaigns
well you know we've got the usual old
men beating each other up with clubs
routine we've got
the grumpy old men routine going on you
have president trump
beating up biden and biting suggesting
that he wants to physically beat up
trump and they suggest they want to
fight each other which i mean for the
record honestly i would have enjoyed a
lot more than this actual campaign which
has been just a bleep show from
beginning to end
here was eric trump and biden going at
it in the final day of the election
do you remember like a year ago year and
a half ago i said
i'd like to take him to the back of the
barn
[Applause]
a slight slap you don't have to close
you didn't close your face now they said
he's inciting violence the president
likes to portray himself i love this
likes to portray himself as a tough guy
when you're in high school wouldn't you
have liked to take the shot
anyway it's a different story but anyway
okay so
it's all good times old men threatening
each other physically is always
it's my kind of politics i'm really
really enjoying it so that that's
that's good times uh the biden also
mocked trump
trump's hair which is very important
yeah i'm told this is a man who raises
the standard of american politics right
he's he's captain classy over here
so he's mocking trump's hair politics is
not a sport for the stupid
obviously it's something we take very
seriously every election is like the
lincoln douglas debates
here's a joe biden so we have a a
gibberish-speaking
nearly senile old democrat versus donald
trump a man
from whom words flow at an
unprecedented rate of bizarreity that's
not even a word
but i've made it up just for president
trump anyway here was uh here was joe
biden
over the weekend mocking trump's hair
there's all this okay you know what
america deserves what it gets
here's joe biden today he said
he is a i think he said perfect physical
specimen maybe that's why he thought he
was able to write off
seventy thousand dollars on his taxes
because he needed special hair care
seriously 70 000 bucks
right written off for hair care i tell
you what man
i hardly have any hair but i'd rather
have what i have
okay um he's had hair plugs everybody
knows that your buttons had earplugs
we used to call them plugs biden all
right
[Music]
okay so everything is incredibly stupid
we're gonna get to
the actual final pitch right you have
the stupidity of the politics then we'll
get to the actual final pitch because
kamala harris kind of let the cat out of
the bag and let me just put it this way
if you are one of these
i'm saving conservatism never trump
folks who have decided
that the way to save conservatism is by
electing biden harris
all i can say is that at this point
you're a useful idiot it's one thing to
sit out the election and say i don't
like either of these candidates i refuse
to participate but to actively vote for
biden harris
knowing what they are promulgating uh is
uh
if you think you're saving conservatism
it's because you're a useful we'll
get to that in one second first
let us talk about your sleep qualities
so let me take as an example
last night so last night finally get to
sleep it's like 11 15
and then my baby wakes up at about 5 00
a.m and then my other kids wake up at
about 6 a.m
well what does that mean it means the
hours between 11 and 5 those better have
been
good hours for me to sleep the good news
is that they were because i have a helix
sleep mattress it is made just for me
helix sleep has a quiz it takes two
minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattresses
the perfect mattress for you whether
you're a side sleeper a hot sleeper
whether you like a plush or a firm bed
with helix there's no more confusion and
no more compromising helix sleep is
rated the number one mattress by gq and
wired magazine cnn called the most
comfortable mattress they've ever slept
on
that's the last time cnn told the truth
just go to helixleep.com take their
two-minute sleep quiz they will match
you to a customized mattress that'll
give you
the best sleep of your life they've got
a 10-year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights at risk-free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you absolutely will
helix is offering up to 200 bucks off
all mattress orders for our listeners
get up to 200 bucks off at
helixsleep.com again that is
helixsleep.com go check them out right
now helixsleep.com okay so president
trump's
final closing pitch on joe biden is that
joe biden has spent his entire career
doing nothing but helping out his family
which effectively speaking is kind of
true right the only major piece of
legislation that joe biden was
responsible for he has now run directly
away from
that of course would be the crime bill
of 1994. here was trump going after
biden in the closing hours of the
election
for decades joe biden let other
countries rip you off
rip off our country and cheat america
blind and there was a group they would
just they would let them do anything
biden has been there
for five decades and the only people who
benefited from his policies were
himself and his family frankly
he shows up every four years and then
goes back to washington and caters to
special interests but my only interest
is you
okay fair enough meanwhile joe biden was
shouting gibberish on the campaign trail
so that was exciting stuff his entire
pitch is that he's not trump right we
all know this
right that it's it's trump versus not
trump that is that it's this entire
election cycle and joe biden is just the
default not trump guy
which means that if he is
indistinguishable from the pumpkin
sitting behind him on a haystack
during his campaigns that's not terrible
for him it is a reminder that he's not
going to be president for very long
okay anybody who thinks that this guy
he's 78 years old that he's gonna be
around for eight years
and then he's gonna be a bullwork
against the hard left they gotta be high
like that's not a thing
here is joe biden speaking gibberish
over the weekend
i'll need an effective strategy to
mobilize true international depression
barack and i think it's a right for
people that bad at healthcare
what what now
um so this is so your one of your big
problems with trump is that he's
inarticulate
and uh and says things that you don't
understand so you're going to
make president a person who doesn't
speak english anymore
who once spoke english as his first
language but no longer speaks
english meanwhile who actually is going
to fill the cabinet so elizabeth warren
apparently has been lobbying very hard
for the treasury secretary position
uh you have bernie sanders lobbying very
hard for secretary of labor so he could
have like a full-on socialist cabinet
under joe biden which would be very
exciting stuff here's amy klobuchar who
is just eating her heart out that joe
biden did not pick her right that would
have been the smart play we would pick
amy klobuchar because minnesota actually
is up for grabs and klobuchar is also
less radical than some of the other
democrats here she was on fox news on
sunday
saying she has no idea who will be in
the cabinet which is definitely
something that makes me much more
comfortable
having a a senile old man who is going
to
make sure that we mobilize behind a true
membership emergency every game
and also that we fix america everything
i don't care
here is uh here's amy klobuchar
right now joe biden is focused on
uniting this country and our party has
stayed united but what i think is really
important to realize
he has brought in people like john
kasich former governor republican
governor of ohio
cindy mccain but he's not going to be
he's not going to be in the cabinet i'm
talking about elizabeth warren
treasury secretary or bernie sanders i
have no idea who he's going to pick for
the cabinet
what i do know is the way he has run
this campaign
the way he said he's going to be the
president not just for the people that
vote for him but the people that vote
against him that's how he's going to
govern
uh no that is not how he's going to
govern now how do we know that that's
not how he is going to govern well first
of all
he labels his opponents just bad people
right this is this is the
the real pitch for democrats is that the
people who vote against strobe are bad
people
so when biden is capable of uh pushing
words
through his face he sometimes says
things like
trump supporters are ugly so here he was
in minnesota over the weekend
suggesting that horn honking trump
supporters are ugly people
this isn't a political statement like
those ugly folks over there
beeping the horns this is a patriotic
duty for god's sake
none of those old people beeping horns
that are getting in a battle
a horde get off my lawn usually you're a
troubled single
name yes yes
get ready for eight years okay it ain't
gonna be eight years of that and we all
know it
which brings us which brings us to the
most important video of the weekend
okay this one was released on purpose by
kamala harris it wasn't like just a
normal
biden gaffe it wasn't like just biden
barely being alive it wasn't kamala
harris dancing in the rain or something
stupid like this
this was an actual video put out by
kamala harris in the waning moments of
the campaign
in which she overtly endorses communism
yes that is that is what happened over
the weekend that is a thing that
actually happened
and the likelihood that she ends up as
president of joe biden ends up as a as
president
very very very high i mean the joe biden
should just watch his step around
slippery stairs if kamala harris is
nearby
he should get a food taster immediately
immediately for the sake of his own
health he should have a
food taster maybe chris christie will
still be available
we'll get sorry chris we'll get to that
in in just one second
first let us talk for just a moment
about life insurance
so speaking of food tasting and life
insurance yeah
you actually do need life insurance if
you are a person who is a responsible
human being and you have dependence you
need to make sure
that you are that your family is
protected in case god forbid something
should happen to you like you get
elected president and then your vice
president is ambitious
you need to make sure they have life
insurance but how do you obtain
excellent life insurance well
you could head over to policygenius.com
right now
you could say 50 or more by using policy
genius to compare life insurance when
you're shopping for a policy that could
last for more than a decade the savings
really do start to add up here's how it
works first
head on over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need you can compare quotes
from top insurers and find your best
price
policy genius will then compare policies
starting at as little as one dollar a
day
you might even be eligible to skip that
in-person medical exam once you apply
the policy genius team handles all the
paperwork and the red tape the best part
they work for you not the insurance
company so
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process they take care of
everything
just for you if you need life insurance
head on over to policygenius.com
right now to get started you could save
50 or more by comparing quotes policy
genius when it comes to insurance it is
nice
and very very important to get it right
okay so
all of this brings us to the video of
the weekend because this is the
democratic party
okay so the democratic party has been
hiding their agenda behind the
behind the potemkin village that is
joe biden right for those who don't know
potemkin villages if you've ever seen
the end of blazing saddles where they
construct an entire fake town just for
the posse to ride into
joe biden is the fake town right joe
biden is just a series of facades
and one nudge and the facade falls over
and there is
kamala harris laughing like the joker
okay so kamala harris
put out a a video over the weekend that
is an explicit endorsement of communism
that's really what it is i'm gonna play
it for you and it is
crazy it is fully crazy so it is about
the
the supposed difference between equality
and equity right so there is a
difference between equality and equity
i've made this point many times
right the idea is that if two people are
in a room and one person has five
dollars and one has one that doesn't
mean something unfair happened
there could be a thousand reasons for
that maybe the person with five dollars
invested well
maybe the person with five dollars worth
more hours maybe the person with five
dollars
provided a good or service worth five
dollars and the person who has a dollar
provided a good or service worth a
dollar there are many many reasons for
discrepancies to exist in life
there are many many reasons for
discrepancies to exist across groups it
is possible
that in any group scenario there will be
in inequalities that does not mean
inequity inequity is unfairness
kamala harris in this video suggests
that the only way
you can ensure that no inequity has
taken place is if everybody ends up in
the same place which is called communism
that is just communism so here she is
explicitly endorsing communism the day
before the election this is wild stuff
from kamala harris who likely will end
up
as president if joe biden is elected so
there's a big difference between
equality and equity
equality suggests oh everyone should get
the same amount
the problem with that not everybody's
starting out from the same place
so if we're all getting the same amount
but you started out back there and i
started out over here
we could get the same up but you're
still going to be that far back behind
me
it's about giving people the resources
and the support that they need
so everyone can pound is going up on
equal footing and then compete
on equal footing equitable treatment
means we all end up at the same place
equitable treatment means we all end up
at the same place
is an insane statement that is an insane
statement
okay equitable treatment means we all
end up in the same place means that the
way that she is judging whether fairness
has taken place
is by the end result so she's just imra
max kennedy right this is
iber max kennedy's point he says that if
if there's any group disparity
right if blacks and whites end up with a
disparate income level if there's an
income gap between blacks and whites
that means
that some inequity has been done to
black people now of course this is
nonsense
there is a statistic that came out over
the week and it shows that asian women
are now earning more on average than
white men
so is that because of inequity is that
because the constitutional system of the
united states
is somehow geared against white men and
on behalf of asian women
how explain okay why is it that people
all over the world have been unable to
achieve equality of outcome
well because many of us have different
qualities right some of us
are very athletic some of us are very
smart some of us are neither
so like we all have different qualities
what we all
have the capacity to do is work hard and
make good decisions
right that's the one thing that you can
do now you can make the argument
that if somebody has been historically
discriminated against that trying to
help them
out give them some extra benefits like a
helping hand in order so that they can
get closer to that start line right this
is something that lyndon baines johnson
suggested in the 1960s
that that would be a good thing the
problem is that when the government
decides that they are responsible for
cosmic justice as thomas soul has said
when the government decides that it is
their job to ensure that everybody ends
up
in the same place at the end of the day
well you end up with this dramatic
inequity
you end up with dramatic unfairness
cruelty malice
you end up having to suppress the
success of some in order to benefit
others who are not making the same
decisions
because again decision making in a free
country is the
chief factor in how your life is going
to go so this assumes of course
that the system is built to keep people
down the system is rigged to keep people
down
and the only way that true equality and
therefore equity
exists is if you rigged the system in
order to help some at the expense of
others
okay that is that's what ibrahim kennedy
says right abram kennedy says injustice
to
injustice yesterday can only be solved
by injustice today injustice today can
only be solved by injustice tomorrow
and the way he defines injustice is
everybody receiving the same thing at
the end of the day
this is a recipe for marxist tyranny the
government does not have the capacity to
ensure that everybody ends up
in an equal outcome all the government
has the capacity to do is ensure that
everyone's equal rights are protected
that's all the government has the
capacity to do
the government does not have the
capacity to do anything else once it
starts picking winners and losers it can
just as easily
pick somebody who doesn't deserve
something as it can
pick somebody who does deserve something
it can just as easily violate somebody's
rights on behalf
of somebody else as it can the reverse
the government is not god a kamala
harris and the democrats are treating
government as god i mean that's an
insane video
and the fact that she put that out
narrated by kamala harris the day before
the election
that is an overt marks a statement it is
not covert it is not subtle
that equality i mean that that final
slide of it right the final
image in which it's two people standing
at the top of the mountain because now
one person has been artificially boosted
so that they can grab the bottom of that
rope and then climb up the mountain
that final but the final statement there
which is that equality
of outcome is the goal all right
all right because it turns out the only
way you can ensure equality of outcome
is to get rid of equal rights
is to get rid of individual rights you
have to treat people as widgets or
moldable
by the social systems in which they live
it ignores that people have natural
differences
it ignores that people make different
decisions it ignores
that there's differences between how
people are brought up there's
differences in environment and home
environment
i mean it just ignores all realities on
the ground
in favor of this this weird and
disgusting
plato's republic vision of a utopian
society in which the government molds
everybody from birth in order to achieve
equal outcome
a lot of people by the way who read
plato's republic this is the sort of
straussian raid
is that a lot of people read plato's
republic think that plato's republic
which talks
basically about a communist utopia is
meant periodically
because plato is smart enough to
recognize how stupid that would be and
that it absolutely would not work
and so that is what you're getting and
joe biden all of this is is him just
soft selling you on what kamala harris
is hard selling you on
so if you love that this is what i said
if you're voting for joe biden in order
to stop donald trump because you think
that joe biden is going to save the
country
or you think you're saving conservatism
because trump is just such a bad guy
so vile so vulgar that you need to vote
to oust him
and then you're putting joe biden and
kamala harris in charge good luck if
you're saving conservatism by electing
out now marxists
good luck to you good luck to you okay
in just a second we're gonna get to the
the intervention of celebrities in the
campaign because that's exciting stuff
plus
some trump biden clashes around the
country will talk about the possibility
of violence which seems to be
getting worse as we near the election
first let us talk about the fact that if
you are
low on energy let's say that you have
children who wake you up at all hours of
the night or let's say that you're one
of my producers and you work for me and
i am a very very demanding human being
this means you need superbeads super
beats soft chews they combine non-gmo
beats with a powerful clinically
researched ingredient
grape seed extract the grapeseed extract
used in super beets chews has been
clinically shown to be twice as
effective at supporting normal blood
pressure as a healthy lifestyle alone
better blood pressure means more energy
the way nature intended without the
jittery caffeine or the stimulants
now you can take just two delicious
shoes a day anytime anywhere to get the
blood pressure support you need
and the energy you want support your
heart health with delicious
super beats choose get your super beats
choose today
at getsuperbeats.com shapiro our
producers
they guzzle them like they are going out
of business because number one they
taste good number two they're very good
for them
when you buy two bags super beats will
throw in the third for free that's get
superbeads.com shapiro
you will enjoy them again special deal
getsuperbeats.com when you buy two bags
they will throw in the third for free
how do i know it's working
because if they hit the rebirth at the
correct time when i say super beat
that means they've been taking their
super beats alrighty
in just a second we're gonna get back to
the campaign
celebrities intervening in the final
days and the media also
putting their two cents in plus we'll
get to lockdown politics anthony fauci
finally coming out of the closet and
basically just endorsing
endorsing joe biden we'll get to that in
a second first
2020 as you may have noticed this year's
been garbage and one of the reasons it's
been garbage is because
all of the festering wounds that were
kind of
bubbling underneath the the skin in
america just boiled out into the open
and those festering wounds are not going
away if joe biden wins or if donald
trump wins there's a deep philosophical
conflict of visions in the united states
i describe it in my book how to destroy
america in three easy steps so one of
the questions i get most often
from people listen to the show is i have
friends i have family i have kids
and they don't know enough about
american philosophy or about
why people are trying to rip it down i
wrote a book about this how to destroy
america in three easy steps is that book
it's relevant before the election is
relevant on election day it is relevant
beyond the election
if you want to understand the conflict
of visions that is happening right now
in the country
you need to read how to destroy america
in three easy steps you should buy it
for your high schooler you should buy it
for a college student
you should buy it for friends and family
because the fact is that if we hope to
change the philosophical direction of
the country
and revivify our fealty to the founding
principles of the country we have to
understand them that's what the book
really is about how to destroy america
in three easy steps go pick it up
right now also in case you missed it we
had another great episode of the sunday
special yesterday
with author columnist documentarian
shelby steele he talked about white
guilt
we talked about racism we talked about
president trump and black lives matter
and all the rest i think it is
enlightening
i think shelby steele is a brave dude go
check out our episode over the weekend
with shelby steele it's really really
worth the watch
go watch right now at dailywire.com or
you can listen on apple podcast spotify
or wherever else you get your podcast
also also as we've been talking about
the democratic party
would love to move the country in a
radically different direction
you just saw kamala harris talking about
how we need equality of outcome joe
biden has pledged over the weekend
more lockdowns more masking joe biden
has promised over the weekend that he
wants to start banning
guns infringing on your second amendment
rights the democrats have
fully endorsed the idea of
intersectional identity as opposed to
individual identity
they believe the founding principles of
the united states are mere covers for
brutality and bigotry
they endorse the 1619 project they
endorse black lives matter they endorse
antifa
all of this is going to be exacerbated
if democrats win
so we are covering the election in
detail and you can watch the election
with us it is a vital election
our live stream starts tuesday november
3rd 3 p.m eastern at 12 p.m pacific
features special guests live interviews
and more
including many surprises leading up to
our evening show we'll be covering the
results with you
in real time even better join dailywire
right now get 25
off with code election so you can watch
all of our election coverage live on our
apple tv or roku app we have so many
surprises so much good stuff for you
go check us out right now make sure you
check us out at dailywire.com and use
that promo code election
for a special deal you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so as everybody ramps up for election
day there's a narrative that has gone
out across the land from the media
and that narrative of course is that the
trump supporters are the ones who are
going to get violent
this is something that that democrats
been pushing for a while even though the
amount of violence that is
driving from trump supporters when it
comes to political violence across the
country
uh we just watched cities burn and the
media tried to proclaim that it was
white nationalists and trump supporters
who were doing the burning which of
course
is very very silly in the lead up to the
election we have seen
that businesses all over blue areas are
boarding up
so this is one of my favorite things
about the media is their their perfect
willingness to ignore
the the absolutely obvious around them
so wolf blitzer over the weekend
he tweeted out a picture of businesses
being boarded up in washington dc
of cnn he tweeted out i never thought i
would see so many buildings here in the
nation's capital boarded up on the eve
of a presidential election
in anticipation of possible unrest and
it's not just in dc
it's happening in new york l.a and
elsewhere around the country so sad
i wonder who's doing that i wonder i
wonder why they're boarding up
businesses in you know every blue area
you think they're doing that because
they're afraid of trump supporters or
could it be
that the media which have steadfastly
refused to acknowledge that left-wing
violence has been plaguing the country
throughout the year
maybe it's those people maybe the fact
is trump supporters are not going to
ride if trump loses but biden supporters
are absolutely going to riot
if donald trump wins maybe it's that and
shockingly the same media
who seems so bewildered by people
boarding up their businesses have been
happily covering and praising the folks
over at black lives matter for the
entire year
a video emerged over the weekend of
black lives matter protesters abusing
cops in new york city
some of them are not wearing masks by
the way but the good news is that the
virus is woke so it doesn't matter at
all
as we know the woke virus does not
affect people as long as they wear a
black lives matter t-shirt and spit on
get cops and killed
i hope that all of your children get
raped and killed but don't worry they're
boarding up businesses because trump
supporters might be really bad
as proof that trump supporters are
really bad democrats have trotted out
video of
a bunch of trump train caravan
supporters this bunch of trucks in texas
surrounding a biden bus
on an interstate apparently according to
the local newspaper the texas tribune
they said the fbi is looking into a
friday incident in which a group of
trump supporters driving trucks and
waving trump flags
surrounded and followed a biden campaign
bus as it drove up i-35 in hayes county
this according to a law enforcement
official the washington post reported
biden staffers called 911 to get a
police
escort to their next location and
they suggested that this was a a you
know
ugly terrible trump supporters who were
trying to slow down the bus
and run it off the road actually what
the vehicles
kind of show is that the the vehicles
the tape seems to show the vehicle
surrounding us again this is stupid
don't do this anybody
it's idiotic okay but they surround the
bus and then a
a biden vehicle starts swerving out of
the uh
out of the lane and moving into the lane
of some of the other trucks you can see
some of the video here
so you can see here all the the trump
trucks and they're surrounding the biden
truck you can see there's a white suv
behind the biden bus and that white suv
actually starts veering out of his lane
uh into a
into a lane where a trump truck is going
again is is all this smart no
is is all this stupid absolutely are
people deeply worried about trumpian
violence after the election
uh i i have serious doubts that that is
in fact the case
there were clashes in beverly hills as
well according to fox news
the beverly hills pd declared an
unlawful assembly saturday after fights
broke out between trump supporters
and counter protesters the usa freedom
rally was planned for 3pm pacific it
featured multiple republican
california congressional candidates a
group of protesters mostly clad in black
marched from roxbury park to the site of
the usa
freedom rally lieutenant max subin of
bhpd told fox news a couple of members
got into a violence attack on a
pro-trump member
so it's antifa that attacked the uh the
trump assembly
shocker i can't believe it uh this was
reported of course as
a clash between trump supporters and
non-trump supporters so
if trump supporters do something wrong
then obviously this is indicative of all
trump supporters if people hate trump
and do violence then it's just a clash
between trump supporters
and trump non-supporters so all sorts of
good stuff happening across the country
meanwhile celebrities have now weighed
in
uh i was waiting i thought it was vital
by the way the best celebrity post of
the weekend actually did not have to do
with the election
per se it came from genius political
voice alyssa milano
so she uh she tweeted out a picture of
herself wearing a ruth bader ginsburg
halloween outfit
and she tweeted out happy halloween rgb
forever
close not quite okay then
she tweeted out she she deleted that
because it turns out that it's uh
rg rbg not rgb then she uh
corrected it and she tweeted out the
same picture happy halloween ruth bader
ginsburg
only one problem she spelled ginsburg
g-i-n-s b-e-r-g
it is with a u so then she deleted it
again
so our celebrity class we need to hear
more from them
absolutely well if you want to hear more
from them lady gaga cut a video telling
you to vote
which is what i needed i need lady gaga
pretending to be
a down-home girl not you know a giant
hollywood starlet who wears weird crap
all the time
uh here she was throwing away a
perfectly good can of beer while telling
people to vote standing next to a truck
which i guess this is what people who
are in
hollywood and they're from new york
think of what people in the middle of
the country look like
i don't know that people in the middle
of the country throw away perfectly good
cans of beer
or dress like they're cosplaying a
hunting outfit
that is that solid stuff here from lady
gaga
hey this is lady gaga i'm voting for
america
which means i'm voting for joe biden
and if you live in minnesota
pennsylvania
georgia michigan florida or arizona
i encourage you to vote and if you have
a friend that lives there
tell them to vote i'm gonna be in one of
these states tomorrow
guess which one i'll be in hint i used
to live there
okay that that of beer still had
beer the 2020 election
okay so if if that motivated you to vote
may i suggest that you never vote again
for the rest of your life
can i can i just suggest that i just i
feel like that's
not like a great thing that was her
worst performance since sin city 2
a dame to kill four i think right not
not a solid performance
that was not quite a star is born stuff
from from lady gaga right there
it was much easier for her to play
herself in in a star is born then to
play
you know like a red state american
meanwhile jeff daniels was brought on tv
it's always exciting to me when jeff
daniels uh cuts political ads because
remember he he's played politicians in
the movies
it's hilarious to me when when
celebrities do this like you've seen
martin sheen do this before it's like i
play a politician in the movies
therefore i am like a politician like
no no you know george clooney played a
doctor on tv if i have a heart attack
i'm not calling george clooney
but here here is jeff daniels lecturing
us all in politics
in michigan we don't pound our chests
and blow our own horns
we just get the job done we suit up
show up and get to work we take
responsibility
here in michigan we don't believe in
paying off porn stars to keep their
mouths shut about who we really are i
need hollywood to lecture me and we
don't think much of a man who
disrespects women
oh you mean like harvey weinstein over
there in fact
we don't think he's much of a man at all
uh
mr give him dessert i'm glad i'm glad
that we had all of these people sound
off
now here's the point that i'm making
listen we can make fun of celebrities
all day and
believe me i would love to because they
are some of the dumbest people in the
world when it comes to this stuff you
know i'm not an expert on cinematography
or lighting and they're not experts on
politics in any way shape or form
but the point that i would like to make
here is that there's been a complete
merger now
between media and celebrity like a
complete merger right jeff daniels will
be featured on on msnbc
as like a regular guest alyssa milano is
featured on cnn regularly
and and my favorite thing about the
media who are really the un's
when we talk about the silent majority
in this country and people say oh maybe
there's a silent majority for trump
there's a very non-silent minority in
the media who are pretending they are
objective that's their that's their
silence
but they're not objective in any way
shape or form they're just part of the
media celebrity culture
in media the washington dc hollywood
new york complex right meaning media in
new york
democratic party in washington d.c
hollywood cop they are all the same
they're all the same barack obama was a
movie star he was not just a president
jeff daniels isn't just a movie star
he's a politician and members of the
media
are not just members of the media
they're celebrities so
how do you know this well over the
weekend i thought this was actually kind
of telling
so kirsty ellie who is a celebrity right
which means
she's entitled to her opinion like
anybody else she happens to be closer to
my side of the aisle on a lot of issues
but i don't think she's an expert
on politics in any real way so kirstie
alley tweeted out something
about how democrats want more lockdowns
cnn's communications team
tweeted out kirsty you are welcome to
change the channel just like countless
viewers did every time veronica's closet
came on tv
but don't downplay the loss of nearly
230 000 american lives and please wear a
mask
cnn is just a celebrity outfit cnn and
tmz are indistinguishable
really i mean like i don't like that's
cnn's coms team responding directly to
kirstie alley don't pretend to me these
are serious people
don't pretend these are serious arbiters
of the truth speaking of non-serious
arbiters of the truth here's brian
stelter
over the weekend a very reliable source
reliably sourcing his journalism
here he was talking about how this
election is a referendum on fantasy and
conspiracy theory tell me more
cnn cnn reliable sources guy
who monitors the fox news channel every
waking hour
but can't spend like 30 seconds 30
seconds checking his own channel for
bias
or foolishness here is brian stelter
suggesting that if donald trump wins
it's a victory for fantasy and
conspiracy theory as opposed to
you know a victory for cnn which would
be technically a referendum on
fantasy and conspiracy theory the coming
days
are a test of american democracy
the world is watching live through this
network and others
america passes this test by staying tied
tethered secured to the truth america
may
fail this test if lying politicians and
propagandists
drown out what's true and replace it
with what they want to be true
failure means succumbing to fantasy and
conspiracy theory
and hate and division and there's
already two too much of that
okay can okay i'm sorry but the the
hypocrisy here is
beyond words and brian selter sounds
exactly like every other celebrity in
hollywood
when he says these things right it's all
about ending hate says cnn
which promoted for sadly like a week
the covington catholic non-scandal right
cnn
which spent its time declaring that
brett kavanaugh was probably a gang
rapist
cnn which trots out people like brian
stelter to dismiss
any sort of questions about andrew cuomo
and chris cuomo and bias at the network
don't pretend i'm supposed to respect
these people as objective journalists
because they are not
we are living the world of fantasy and
conspiracy theory when you pretend that
cnn is objective journalism it simply is
not it simply is not
and they aren't even trying anymore and
speaking of fantasy and conspiracy
theory
notice something democrats right now
they keep talking about how republicans
they have this conspiracy theory about
voter fraud there's gonna be tons of
voter fraud
now listen i don't think there's a lot
of evidence that there's widespread
voter fraud
we've had evidence in particular
districts there's an evidence actually a
voter fraud being used in a north
carolina district by a republican
we've had evidence of voter fraud in
minnesota we've had we've had evidence
of voter fraud in washington state
it depends on the race in close margin
and very narrow
going sometimes voter fraud can make a
difference it can
but are we talking about like hundreds
of thousands or millions of ballots
that are being put out there via voter
fraud i i don't think so i don't see
evidence of that
at this point but the same people who
are saying we shouldn't worry about
voter fraud on the left
are saying we should deeply worry about
voter suppression so the same media
telling you
that we are you know that this is a
referendum on truth and fantasy
they're suggesting that we are going to
that if donald trump wins it can only be
due to voter suppression they're
pressing this
narrative like nothing they're pressing
this narrative every single moment of
the day
the built-in excuse is ready the same
media that why why in the world are they
boarding up all the windows in
washington dc
while ignoring antifun black lives
matter why exactly are they boarding up
all the windows in washington dc i mean
i mean also at the same time saying that
if trump wins it can only be through
voter suppression
um i think i know why they're boarding
up all the windows in washington dc
my people i kind of get it i kind of get
it the democrats are pushing this
narrative as well here's ayanna presley
over the weekend
saying that uh long lines are voter
suppression if there are long lines of
the polls that's voter suppression
nope voter suppression is uh like when
bull conor turns fire hoses on black
people that that's voter suppression
voter suppression is like when sanam
hussein gasses the kurds voter
suppression
is like when there's an actual poll tax
designed to disenfranchise people
voter suppression is not when you have
to wait in line for a thing that is
called waiting in line for a thing
here's ayanna presley pushing
voter suppression is a theory and cnn
nodding right along
we still find ourselves in the civil
rights movement
and right now we have the opportunity to
write the next chapter in our civil
rights history
you know what were fire hoses and dogs
are today's what happened in my district
arson at drop boxes
is voter uh voter suppression
intimidation
uh with long lines so it is just more of
the same but it is also why we must be
more emboldened than ever before
when our democracy our livelihood and
our very lives are
all on the ballot our lives are on the
ballot so democrats say our lives are on
the ballot
voter suppression is the only way trump
can win and then cnn's like but why is
everybody afraid of violence it's got to
be the trump supporters right it's all
the trump people
it's all the trump people okay well the
final closing argument for democrats in
the end
is basically twofold right it's that
donald trump is a very bad bad man mean
man very bad and orange and all that
and it's also that america is bad and
therefore if trump
wins it's because america is bad if
trump loses america is still bad but
they've had a moment a moment a glimmer
of hope
but if trump wins then it has to be
because of voter suppression and fire
hoses
and dogs i mean the fact that there's no
pushback by don lemon there
on ayanna presley tells you what you
need to know about the media democratic
complex
aided and assisted by the folks in
hollywood okay so
there is also another aspect of the
pitch when it comes to donald trump
being very very bad we all know this the
final closing pitch for democrats and
why donald trump is very very bad
is because donald trump is a mesmatic
evil force across the land
responsible for covet right there's
there's an almost biblical view
that democrats in the media have of
covid which is that america deserves
this and because we elected donald trump
we deserve this they had the same view
by the way of the wildfires in
california
joe biden said similar stuff about
global warming like if we get rid of
donald trump global warming will stop
it we'll cease almost immediately it's
amazing he has said if we elect him
there will be no there will be fewer
wildfires in california
which um no just no that is that it's
anti-scientific nonsense
but the but the basic philosophy here is
that donald trump
is a mesmatic evil force lying over the
land
and that the only way to relieve that
mesmatic evil force is to get rid of him
and we have been struck with the plague
america has we were struck with the
plague because donald trump was elected
president
and if donald trump were not president
then the plague would go away
and this has been this this sort of
logic
has been shown through the prism of
covid
right covet itself is now a referendum
on trump
if it weren't for trump coveted would
just go away it would just go away
because there there's apparently a big
red button in the white house labeled
stop covet and trump refuses to push it
because trump is coveted covid
is trump now from trump's perspective
he's saying
listen i'm not pushing lockdowns because
lockdowns are bad policy
and guess what we've locked down we've
watched europe lockdown and europe is
now spiking higher than the united
states is by leaps and bounds
but all of this coveted talk is being
refracted through that lens right that
prism of
trump is bad and evil and everything
coveted related is about
trump so trump happens to be more
accurate about this than the democrats
are he actually is
when trump said not about the efficacy
of masks
not about the deadliness of the disease
but when trump suggests
that this is a choice between a vaccine
and a lockdown
and that lockdowns are bad policy he's
not wrong about this there are a variety
of policy choices that are on the table
none of them are good
none of them are good and trump's
actually being more realistic about this
than democrats in the media are
but for democrats in the media
understand that it doesn't matter what
policy is chosen
the only policy that they care about in
terms of getting rid of covet is getting
rid of trump
there is an almost religious belief and
almost faith-based belief
that if donald trump exits office if
he's if he's thrown out of office
on november 3rd that coveted will
immediately wane across the country
because the adults will be in charge
it's just not true
here's trump making the case instead
that lockdowns are bad policy which
happens to be true this election is a
choice between a
biden depression or a trump super bomb
we're going to be booming
could have the greatest year yeah the
best year we've ever had last year we're
going to have the best year
next year we're set for it it's a choice
between
a deadly biden lockdown he wants to lock
down
we're never locking down or a safe
vaccine that
ends the pandemic and we frankly we're
going to end it anyway the vaccines are
coming
okay so trump is providing an actual
choice here right he's talking about
policy preferences but for democrats
understand it's not about the policy
it's about the man
and so anthony fauci has lent his
support now to this and
as i've said before i've been i think
quite
willing to listen to anthony fauci in
his statement i've said all along
anthony fauci engages in single factor
analysis his single factor analysis is
how do i prevent covet deaths under any
circumstances and if that means that i
lock everybody's front doors and i weld
them in their houses
essentially then that's what we should
do right anthony kova
anthony fauci has been from the
beginning about single factor analysis
he has not looked at the downside of
lockdowns really
he refuses to talk about the downside of
lockdowns when he does he does so in
vague terms
he suggests that masks are capable of
doing more than they are capable of
doing
and and now he's very upset at trump and
he's speaking out publicly
like in the days before the election
about how much he dislikes trump listen
to the way that he poses this anthony
fellowship okay this is according to the
washington post
president donald trump's repeated
assertions the united states is rounding
the turn on the novel coronavirus have
increasingly alarmed the government's
top health experts who say the country
is heading into a long and potentially
deadly winter with an unprepared
government unwilling to make tough
choices
we're in for a whole lot of hurt it's
not a good situation anthony fauci the
country's leading infectious disease
expert
said in a wide-ranging interview late
friday all the stars are aligned in the
wrong place as you go into the fall and
winter season with people congregating
at home indoors
you could not possibly be positioned
more poorly
well actually i think that there are
ways we could be positioned more poorly
for example
what if hospitalization rates weren't
down 80 what if we were seeing spikes
in all of the southern states like the
spikes that we saw in new york
originally
which we're not seeing by the way what
if new york we're seeing a second spike
like we've been seeing
in new york originally that isn't
happening in fact as it turns out
the best guarantee of having a massive
second wave is to have a very small
first wave
the harder you lock down i've been
saying this for months the harder you
lock down in the first place the worse
it's going to be when you release the
lockdown this is what you are seeing
all over europe fauci said the united
states needed to make an abrupt change
in public health practices and behaviors
he said the country could surpass a
hundred thousand new coronavirus cases a
day
and predicted rising deaths in the
coming weeks okay that's that's true
he spoke as the nations had a new daily
record friday with more than 98 000
cases
as hospitalizations increased deaths are
also ticking up with more than a
thousand reported wednesday and thursday
fauci's blunt warnings come as trump has
rallied in states and cities
experiencing record surges and
infections and hospitalizations in a
last-ditch effort to convince voters he
has successfully managed
the pandemic fauci said that the and
here's where he gets to the part that
matters fauci said former vp joe biden's
campaign is quote taking it seriously
from a public health perspective
trump thought she said is looking at it
from a different perspective he said
that perspective
was the economy and reopening the
country okay well it turns out
that you have to actually take into
account both of those things right you
can't ignore
the economy and reopening the country by
looking at it only from a quote unquote
public health perspective there are
public health consequences to locking
people down
for years on end their public health
consequences to shutting down the
schools their public health consequences
to the kind of policies that joe biden
is promising at this point
but of course fauci is now lending his
support to the idea that only only
biden is taking this stuff super
seriously and then trump of course falls
directly into the trap of saying maybe
he's going to fire anthony fauci
now the reality is that anthony fauci
should have a very specific role inside
the government
his role inside the government should be
to talk about the dangers of the virus
okay but he was immediately put out
front this is a mistake he was
immediately put out front to talk about
covet policy that is not his job he is
not the policy guy
because the policy guy is supposed to be
the person you elect
nor is it a solution to say as joe biden
does that you're just gonna shut
everything down
nonetheless trump being drawn into a
late minute battle with fouchy is
exactly what democrats have wanted since
march
here was trump at a rally suggesting
he's going to fire fouch after the
election which is a bad closing pitch
considering fouchy is more popular than
the president by polling data
[Applause]
don't tell anybody but let me wait till
a little bit after the election
this all plays into the media's general
narrative about covet and again the
media's narrative is that religious
narrative that's
also joe biden's narrative it's not
about policy it isn't
okay remember joe biden's actual state
of policy is no different than donald
trump's except he says masks and
lockdowns more
okay but the media have bought into this
so here was chris wallace over the
weekend
suggesting hasn't trump failed at
containing the virus
well hasn't everyone failed to contain
the virus i'm sorry we couldn't
transform the united states into a small
island nation like new zealand
i'm sorry that a country of four million
people in a
less in a in a lightly trafficked area
of the world is not the same as a
country of 330 million people in one of
the most heavily trafficked areas of the
world on planet earth
my bad but this media narrative is a lie
it is a lie that has been promulgated
and it's a lie that they're going to use
to try and club trump out of office
here is chris wallace pushing it dr
anthony fauci the government's top
expert on infectious disease tells the
washington post today
we're in for a whole lot of hurt you
could not possibly be
positioned more poorly he says he hasn't
spoken to the president since early
october
corey hasn't the president failed at his
biggest
job this year containing the virus
okay that question is so loaded no one
has contained the virus germany hasn't
contained the virus the uk hasn't
contained the virus france has not
contained the virus the hell is he
talking about
and by the way again if you look at the
states that are experiencing up surges
right now they are all the states that
did not experience an upsurge in the
first place
so basically once it burns through an
area it's burned through the area
i've been saying that for months and it
seems to continue to be the case if you
look on a county by county basis the
place's hardest hit the first time
are the least hard hit the second time
so what kind of policy are you
recommending that's going to be good
and here's the reality joe biden isn't
recommending policy that's going to be
good right so joe biden just
puts out these faith-based insane
statements joe biden literally tweeted
this out over the weekend you ready
i'm not going to shut down the country
i'm not going to shut down the economy
i'm going to shut down the virus how to
put this bluntly how to put the how to
put this
uh genteely bullsh
okay i'm going to shut down the virus
how are you going to fart on it
what are you how are you gonna shut down
the virus joe really i'd love to hear it
i'd love to hear how joe biden is gonna
show and if he knows the answer
then what exactly is the answer if he's
got a hit in his back pocket right there
to shut down the virus how explain it's
like really
detail for me how you going to shut down
the virus the answer is the entire media
infrastructure and bolstered by by
fouchy
saying that biden takes it very
seriously
their argument is that once trump is out
then the virus will wane
okay he's not gonna shut down the virus
because no one is capable of shutting
down the virus the hell are you talking
about we can't transform ourselves into
new zealand
we can't transform ourselves into south
korea we're not gonna
weld people into their houses europe is
getting hit worse than we are it's
amazing how the media went from europe
is handling this exactly right we should
be handling this
exactly like you're up to europe never
heard of europe what is europe is europe
a continent
who is europe it's like they just come
europe is gone it's incredible europe
for months was why can't we handle this
like the italians did
why can't we handle this like the
spaniards why can't we handle this like
the french or the germans we should be
handling this like the europeans then
they spike worse than we are it's like
i've never heard of europe europe is not
a place europe is an idea europe is a
fantasy
okay it's all nonsense no joe biden
isn't going to shut down the virus any
more than joe biden is going to moonshot
cancer
he's been saying that for years i'm
going to create a moon shot a moon shot
really because it turns out that most of
humanity has apparently not been
focusing
sufficiently on trying to stop cancer it
turns out that we've not been spending
billions of dollars
to try and stop cancer joe biden's going
to do it he's going to get in office
and he's going to stop death joe biden
is going to stop death he can't
he can't stop himself from falling apart
but he can stop death
that he can stop if you believe this
it's because you wish it to be true
you are wish casting this crap over the
weekend joe biden
tried to explain how he was going to
shut down the virus he's going to push a
national mass mandate he himself has
said is unconstitutional
we're going to act to get covert under
control on day one of my presidency i'll
put an action
a plan i've been taking about talking
about for months already laid out
a national mandate masquerading social
distancing testing tracing
all things as president obama just said
that should have been could have been
put in place months and months ago all
the things massachusetts and the
temperatures
that they have in europe okay testing
and tracing they have in europe
you know what you know what happened
with testing and tracing nothing it
turns out the only way you can test in
traces if case count is low and there's
no community spread
tr i i am eager to hear from joe biden
how he plans to test and trace in a
country with a hundred thousand new
infections a day
seriously really really eager to hear
about it how he's gonna test and trace
does he plan to employ all 330 million
americans including children in the
testing and tracing process
that's a hell of a government employment
program but don't worry he has the
solution he's going to shut down the
virus
he's going to just shut it down and
that's going to solve everything
meanwhile andrew cuomo whose book was
chosen by amazon editors as one of the
best of the year
again the title of it should have been
if i did it like o.j simpson
but he's he's captain i'm shutting down
the virus after letting it wipe out
every old person in new york here is
andrew cuovo over the weekend so he's
he's rolling out a new policy his new
policy is he's going to mandatorily test
everyone entering new york for kovid now
number one
there are serious problems with doing
mass testing in this way because you end
up with an awful lot of false positives
and an awful lot of false negatives
right tests are not perfect beyond that
it has been long time fda policy that
mandatory testing
of the healthy is generally bad policy
nonetheless
here was andrew cuomo declaring that
he's basically shutting down a state not
to connecticut and new jersey by the way
but to everybody else because he's
handled it so brilliantly so he is going
to try and turn
new york into an island nation we'll see
how that goes for andrew
you are coming to the state of new york
within three days of
arriving in new york
you must have tested negative
and have proof of a test within three
days
upon your arrival in new york that says
you're negative once you arrive in new
york
you must quarantine for three days
and then can take a test
on the fourth day and if
the test on the fourth day says you are
negative
then god bless you're released from
quarantine
yeah um that's not gonna work and uh
there are several reasons it's not gonna
work one
not everybody's gonna do the test two
the incubation period on covet is two to
five days
not three seriously if he's gonna do
this he actually has to quarantine
everybody for like a week
it doesn't work if you let's say that
you were exposed to covid
and then you traveled and you waited
three days and then you tested negative
guess what you could still be positive
for covid
okay that's not the way any of this
works it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter this is all posturing bullcrap
it's gonna spread where it's gonna
spread the only thing you can do is lock
it down and if you lock it down all
you're doing is delaying the impact
again all of this is based on this
bizarre weird notion
that there's a way to control this we
know the answer we know the answer
okay we don't know the answer nobody
knows the answer it's a bunch of hogwash
but it's part of a broader narrative and
the broader narrative is everything is
trump's fault
again it goes back to that religious
belief that if we get rid of trump all
problems are solved
okay well i think that people are going
to um find out very quickly that if
jobiden is elected not all problems are
solved
here's actually my prediction of what
happens with covet if joe biden
is elected if your biden is elected what
you're going to watch is a continuation
of case load
across the winter because that's going
to happen no matter what anybody does or
no matter what anybody says
right because people are going to go
indoors it's going to be cold in the
northeast it's going to be
it's all the areas of the country that
are coldest right now that are getting
hit so during the winter there's going
to be that second wave that everybody
talks about and some k
in most cases it actually constitutes a
first wave because
in many areas that were already hard hit
they're not going to get a big second
wave
okay so you're not going to see a huge
second wave
in arizona or in florida or in texas you
are going to see a big
wave in the states you are currently
seeing a big wave
and there will be increased deaths
because even though we have gotten
better at treating this in hospitals
it is still true that along with
increased case load comes increased
death
by january it's already gonna be going
down right because just like
this is what happened in march right it
went up in march it went up in april by
may it was already starting to come down
it's gonna go up in november it's gonna
go up in december by january it's
already gonna start to come down
by the third week of january when joe
biden would take office
it will already be on the downside of
the curve joe biden will then declare a
national mass mandate regardless of
whether it is constitutional
and he will do a big speech asking
everybody to socially distance and then
the curve which is already starting to
decline will continue to decline and
then joe biden will declare that he has
defeated covet
that is my prediction bank on it okay
put that
seriously seal it put in the time
capsule we'll uncover it on january 31st
of next year if joe biden wins victory
and we'll see if i was right
because all of this has to create it's
all about the political myth
and the deeper political myth okay what
that really ties into is the deeper
political myth that democrats have been
purveying for generations which is that
government is the solution to all your
problems
government cannot solve every problem
government can't solve cancer government
can't solve coven
and government can't solve the problems
of inequality of outcome
but if you're a true believer in the
state if you're a true believer in
marxism if you're a true believer in the
idea that the state controls all
aspects of life this is where you end up
and that's really what the election is
about
the election is about whether you get to
control your life or whether these guys
are going to control your life
if you want to make it about a battle of
personalities and that's what you decide
to do
all right i mean you can but it's you
treating politics foolishly politics is
about who gets to control your life
you or people in washington dc who say
they can solve all your problems
and if you believe the latter you're the
sucker if you can't spot the sucker in
the room
it's you alrighty we'll be back later
today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow for election day
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam scie event
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nico geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2020 poland bans
abortions muslims murder christians in
france
and the biden harris campaign embraces
socialism check it out on the michael
knowles show